hurricane Ian is getting ready for a new
assault on the Southeast the storms
expected to make its second landfall on
the coast of South Carolina this
afternoon forecasters say
life-threatening flooding in storm surge
is likely Mark Strassman is in
Charleston as the coastal city braces
for what's to come Mark good morning
hey Nate good morning to you well and
you can see it's starting here in
coastal communities like Charleston
Warrior they could become Ian's second
Bullseye and after Florida this wrecking
ball of a storm has everyone's attention
around noon today the misery Factor
could kick in with the Vengeance up and
down the Carolinas
the City of Charleston has opened up
Emergency Shelters giving out sandbags
residents and are now racing to protect
their homes and businesses National
Guard troops are also already in
position just in case this part of the
coast is known as the low country
because so much of it sits at or below
sea level especially vulnerable to
flooding in the forecast with Ian a
storm surge of up to seven feet one more
issue Ian's noon arrival coincides with
high tide today that is bad timing there
are no evacuation orders here but with a
Storm's second U.S Landing now hours
away in Georgia and the Carolinas more
than two and a half million people are
under a hurricane warning Charleston is
an old city it's weathered a lot of
storms over the years it's proved it can
take a punch but people here have also
seen enough of them to know that storms
like Ian can be big trouble
Tony
yeah and Ian was hard to predict the
path there on the Gulf Coast so we'll be
monitoring it there in the Atlantic mark
thank you very much and